what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so this is gonna be a pretty short
video guys we're gonna run over the
planet of apocalypse as it exists under
Darkseid I think it's kind of cool I
don't know if we'll actually see it in
the movie but I think it will be kind of
interesting because there there's some
interest on the planet apocalypse and
there is information out there the
problem is that the information is scant
I mean really after the events at new 52
we don't have a whole lot of information
on the planet of apocalypse instead a
lot of the stuff we're gonna be going
over here comes from the original Jack
Kirby stuff in the 1970s really running
up to 1985 and it really just kind of
stops after that but the planet
apocalypse was created by color book
legend Jack Kirby after he left Marvel
for DC in the early 1970s and was
introduced in the new gods number 1 in
1971 now while at DC Kirby mostly
dedicated his time to constructing a
line of comics known as the Fourth World
in which he wanted to present a battle
between good and evil
that was not my 'red by all the DC
continuity that had existed up to that
point and the way that he did this was
by creating two planets one was called
New Genesis which was an idealistic
utopia meant to mirror heaven and the
other was Apocalypse which was basically
just a really dark evil place now these
two planets were actually once part of
one planet called Earth run that thing
is how you pronounce it which was the
home of the old gods which are pretty
much just the gods of classical
mythology now Iran was eventually
destroyed which led to the creation of
new Genesis and apocalypse now as for
the layout of the planet is basically
one gigantic city that spans the entire
surface of the planet with a singular
focus of manufacturing the means for
their ongoing war against New Genesis
now several continually erupting fire
pits are scattered throughout the planet
as well and they're basically the
planets only defining physical feature
so basically imagine of planet sized
weapons Factory and that's pretty much
what apocalypse is now despite its
terrible landscape the technology
produced on apocalypse is among the most
advanced in the entire DC universe also
of note is the fact that apocalypse can
only be accessed by technology that
allows for the opening of boom tubes or
teleportation devices most commonly
these come in the form of mother boxes
but the system of government on
apocalypse is actually pretty simple
it's ruled unilaterally by the brutal
dictator Darkseid now if you don't know
who Darkseid is I have a whole video
where I go in-depth into his character
but he's one of the new gods and ascends
to the throne of apocalypse
by murdering both his brother Drax and
his mother Hydra and he now rules
apocalypse as an absolute tyrant and
strives to eliminate free will from the
universe now assisting Darkseid in his
dictatorship are his elite which
function as a sort of military advisory
council that performs various
governmental functions on apocalypse
itself one of the highest-ranking
members of that particular government is
Darkseid's brother desaad whose sadistic
nature in love of torture haunted
Darkseid
- named desaad his head of torturer and
he also plays a role in overseeing the
day-to-day operations of apocalypse you
know like when Darkseid is busy trying
to find ways to wipe out all life on
earth barbecuing I have no idea
now also part of Darkseid's elite is
stefan wolf who's the main villain of
the Justice League movie although nobody
knows why and who Darkseid has given
command of his armies - and the title of
Master General now just to give you guys
an idea of how weird and somewhat
interesting Jack Kirby's DC stuff is one
of Steppenwolf's primary
responsibilities as commander of the
army of Darkseid is to lead the dog
cavalry which is exactly what it sounds
like mounted soldiers riding on horse
sized dogs it's actually pretty amazing
if you think about imagine like you're
on earth Darkseid attacks earth and like
soldiers riding horse sized dogs come
running at you I would be both like
terrified and like I'd take pictures I
would just be like oh man who Twitter
won't believe this it would be crazy but
anyway there are a few more members that
we need to touch on briefly including
devil ants the pursuer who Darkseid is
basically tasked with hunting down
victims that Darkseid orders him to
capture kanto whose dark sides master
assassin and probably the creepiest of
them all granny goodness granny goodness
as her name suggests has the appearance
of an elderly woman and she's actually
in charge of training Darkseid soldiers
as well as running the orphanages on
apocalypse now as you might have guessed
the way the granny goodness treats the
children in her orphanages is more like
the way that you would treat prisoners
than children as they function basically
as military schools where children are
taught to have blind devotion to
Darkseid if you've been reading Tom
King's mr. miracle series and you get a
pretty good glimpse at what kind of
caretaker granny goodness is I mean I'm
not gonna go too in depth into it just
because of the fact that it is like 12
issues long we're only a few issues into
it so we don't really know what all is
gonna happen with the rest of the story
but suffice it to say the cruel
treatment that granny goodness gives to
her children has like these super long
lasting psychological effects but the
primary duty of great
goodness is to lead Darkseid's
pre-eminent fighting force the female
Furies now the female Furies are in
elite squadron of highly trained and
especially cruel soldiers that are
fiercely loyal to dark side imagine a
fighting force of like five or six
wonder women that's that's really the
level they're on they're extremely
capable in terms of what they could do
when they show up like Superman would
struggle to take on all the female
Furies by himself like a bee it's it's
wild is this really really cool yeah
again you don't see him all the time
which is kind of disappointing like big
Barda the girlfriend of uh I guess maybe
even the wife of Scott free aisle number
how their whole relationship exists in
the new 52 you like she was a female
fury who basically defected but it's
cool it's kind of an interesting little
scenario there now beneath Darkseid's
elite and the hierarchy are the
parademons now the parademons comprise
the police force of apocalypse and are
incredibly loyal and obedient to
Darkseid they're armed with powerful
weapons which they can use to keep
citizens in line and are often
accompanied by enormous dogs called
hounds so yeah
for whatever reason apocalypse is all
about giant dogs giant dogs all over the
place but parademons are noted for their
sadistic nature and are able to
withstand a massive amount of pain which
makes them ideal for suppressing any
civil unrest that may occur on
apocalypse but the way that they
developed this pain tolerance is by
literally being burned in the fire pits
of Apokolips
now something funny to keep in mind here
when it comes to how it is that para
demons are made the whole basis behind
their creation has watched and waned
over the years if you go read the old
Jack Kirby stuff in like the 1970s I
want to say that the para demons are
basically genetically engineered were
just to say that they were just kind of
bread using you know DNA splicing and
different things like that if you go
read like the new the new stuff from DC
from new 52 the para demons are actually
Rima T realized citizens basically
Darkseid will show up on a planet she'll
start rounding up citizenry and then
he'll basically put them through a
process where they'll experience genetic
modification pre materialization and
they'll end up becoming para demons but
at the bottom of society on apocalypse
exists a class of oppressed people
fittingly called the lolis now the lolis
are really just like the slave class of
citizens on apocalypse they're badly
mistreated and many of them are
prisoners of Darkseid that were brought
to apocalypse from planets the dark side
has destroyed or conquered now
interestingly enough there does seem to
be some upward mobility for lolis that
prove themselves exceptionally useful
or loyal to darkside and at one point
granny goodness was actually a member of
the lowly class before she entered into
military training so yeah that's pretty
much the rundown in Apocalypse again not
a whole lot to go on
for some reason DC doesn't really
provide like this super in-depth
complicated look at the nature of
apocalypse I wish they would I wish they
would just have like an entire comic
that doesn't do anything more than just
like explore the planet of apocalypse
but at the end of the day there does
really seem to be a whole lot of
interest in the planet itself outside of
just a passing curiosity more so than
like an interest in like whether or not
Darkseid is gonna succeed in conquering
the world but I think the whole concept
of apocalypse is cool but if you are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all with oh by the way
I'm working on making an audio book so I
have attached the audio book to this
video and hopefully you guys dig it I
mean no visuals it's just an audio thing
with a little bit of like a little music
interface thing but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
because I'm kind of curious is really my
first time trying to put music to audio
books so I'm still trying to figure out
the whole idea of where my voice should
be and like relation to the music itself
and so on and so forth auto ducking is a
lot harder than it seems but let me know
what you guys think about that whole
thing it's the first chapter of Alice in
Wonderland and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]